Speaker 1: Let's get now to maga world exploding
over the fbi raiding Donald Trump's house.
They are throwing everything at the wall to
see what sticks.
They're all going crazy.
They're doing emergency podcast.
They're saying this is going to be the undoing
of the republic.
It is a dystopian hellscape.
It is over for the United States because of
the FBI raiding Donald Trump.
Let's look at some examples.
These are great.
Here's Mark Levin calling this one of the
worst attacks on the republic in modern history.
Speaker 3: Now, you keep asking your guests,
what's the justification?
There is no justification.
What's he going to say tomorrow?
The attorney general.
Here's my guest.
We've been negotiating with Trump and his
lawyers since February when we found out they
had this information.
We were getting nowhere.
And then we know or we heard that some documents
were being destroyed.
Maggie Haberman of The New York Times was
on CNN.
They've been running pictures of hers that
she's going to have in the book of documents
being flushed down a toilet.
That doesn't mean a damn thing.
It can be anything.
Speaker 2: With only Stefanik's name on it.
That's all it was.
Speaker 3: Okay, but what I'm saying is you've
asked what would the pretext be?
Correct.
And so it is a pretext is exactly right.
There is no justification for sending 30 friggin
FBI agents to the former president's compound
in Mar a Lago in early morning and conducting
themselves this way or in any other cases
in which they've done exactly the same thing.
The FBI is corrupt.
This guy, Garland, goes after parents.
He goes after Republican state legislatures.
He goes after states.
He disagrees with their abortion positions.
He doesn't do a damn thing to protect the
border, which has compelled by the Constitution
nothing.
So let's be clear.
Newt is right there.
All right.
This is the worst attack on this republic
in modern history.
Speaker 1: So Levin is flipping out.
But the truth is, this would not have happened
were there not significant I's dotted and
T's crossed.
Next, we go to Newsmax guest Bernie Kerik,
not a guy unfamiliar with legal problems and
he said he's worried.
The next step is they're going to assassinate
Donald Trump.
Speaker 2: And I just put out a tweet about
this.
If you remember back in 2016 where I went
right before he got elected, I was in Washington,
D.C.
I was at a couple different social events
and I heard people talking.
They said the Democrats want this guy so bad
that they wouldn't put assassination behind
it.
And I'm going to tell you something.
They've tried impeachment.
They've tried another impeachment.
They've tried one investigation after another.
This is about one thing.
This is about stopping him from running in
2024.
And I'm going to tell you something.
I'm not into conspiracies.
I'm not into.
Anti-government rhetoric.
This is the first time in my lifetime that
I would say I am deathly afraid for Donald
Trump.
I would not put assassination behind these
people.
Speaker 1: Right.
A raid based on probable cause, a warrant
signed by a judge and everything done properly
could very clearly be a pretext to assassinating
Donald Trump.
Here's radical Republican Congresswoman Lauren
Boebert saying This is the Gestapo.
Speaker 4: Guys, I'm pissed.
We are a nation of law and order.
And this raid by the FBI on President Trump's
home is totally un-American.
This is Gestapo crap, and it will not stand.
Speaker 1: Well, you know, I don't remember
the Gestapo regularly having sworn affidavits,
court order signed by a judge and all of it
when they conducted raids.
Many such examples, I think you understand.
Alex Jones and Roger Stone are convening an
emergency podcast over the raid, likening
it to Nazi Germany.
Speaker 2: As a former political prisoner
himself and what he believes this means.
Roger Stone, thanks for joining us on this
emergency broadcast.
Speaker 1: It's an emergency, Alex.
Speaker 2: It's a it's a very, very sad day
for America.
This is the kind of thing you expect to see
in Soviet Russia, Nazi Germany, communist
Cuba.
Speaker 1: They don't know how to handle this.
Sean HANNITY, we covered this last night on
the live stream.
He spoke for about 11 minutes without taking
a breath.
And here is some of his dystopian outlook
on what took place.
Speaker 2: First, a dark day for our republic,
the Department of Justice, the rule of law.
Well, it looks to be potentially a shocking
overreach.
We'll find out in due time.
That will have serious ramifications potentially
for many, many years to come.
Speaker 1: A lot of potential is in there,
potentially doing very, very heavy lifting
for Sean HANNITY.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE now says on Twitter,
quote, Defund the FBI, not exactly support
the police type behavior by Marjorie Taylor
GREENE.
And then lastly, right wing bomb thrower Dan
Bongino saying that the left thinks this is
all hilarious.
Speaker 2: I just want to say in closing,
listen, America, they're laughing at you.
The left thinks this is hilarious.
If you doubt me.
Just go to any of their goofy platforms, Twitter
or elsewhere.
Right now out.
They think this is hilarious.
Speaker 1: Now, I have to tell you, Bongino
is correct to a certain degree.
I do think this is absolutely hilarious.
But it also seems to be completely appropriate
based on the facts that we have known for
a very long time.
No one that commits crimes against the American
people should feel safe.
And there's a lot of people that commit crimes
and do feel safe because we have a two tiered
justice system.
We don't know where this will go, but we are
going to follow it.
And you've got to see Eric Trump's reaction
to all of this.